this ever happen to you are you peeing
on me yeah well what are you gonna do
buddy
nothing he's right luckily I find this
tutorial on how to draw a horse
hopefully that'll help all right for the
final step I got damnit
I am a vegetarian but I want to eat your
face hello 911 report a vegetarian yes
yes he is trying to eat my face oh wait
I was supposed to get one of the drinks
a hurry
god damn it which one that I put the
drugs in I got damn it I forgot I better
drink both but I need to know if you're
the chosen one that I asked it's holy
ah how can we if I have 26 million
subscribers while there's only 7 to 80
million people at herb fake a [ __ ] I I
don't know how to explain that to you
you might just die from a brain fart